is there a lag
okay stand by here we go
hello
i think we are up now so uh thanks for
joining our uh morning a live stream
here at khan academy we're calling it
something of a of a home room a national
home room or international home room i
guess uh and you know every day we are
trying uh different types of technology
so we're trying new technology today
hopefully it works out but definitely
bear with us i think we've definitely
improved from earlier this week when i
was operating uh from my not so great
wi-fi uh but but things have improved so
you know thanks for joining for those of
y'all uh this is the first day that
you're joining this homeroom it's really
a
way for all of us to connect as i'm sure
many of you know and are experiencing uh
we now have over 40 million students in
america who are now
uh not in physical school they are
they're they're trying to learn from
home and we have approaching a billion
kids around the world who are in that
situation and over the last few well
really over the last decade khan academy
has inadvertently been building things
that can hopefully help folks navigate
this school closure situation this is a
very sub-optimal situation
but
we have over the years created things
like khan academy kids for early
learners that's for ages three through
six covers the head start standards all
the way through first grade and reading
writing math social emotional learning
then i guess you could say the main khan
academy whether you're on the website or
you're on our app
it
goes for sure all the way in math
through elementary middle and high
school and even some of the core of
college a lot of people associate us
with videos it's not just videos in fact
most of what we put resources to are
interactive exercises that have
solutions to every problem students
should never be able to run out of
practice they get feedback there's game
mechanics to make sure they really
master the concepts there's data and
reporting for teachers or parents if
they want to help the students progress
we've recently launched a beta which is
kind of a first draft version of our
english and language arts it's not quite
as rich as what we have on the mat side
but the exercise items i think are
quite good that goes from second through
eighth grade and then as you get into
high school not only do we have the math
but we also have the sciences biology
chemistry physics
economics computer science for those of
you in middle school i actually highly
recommend high school biology i think
you have the math background to handle
it and it's very relevant to the world
that we're in today and we also have sat
practice in reading writing and math and
that's an official partnership with with
the sat so we're with the college board
and you have all of those resources and
we realized last week that we got to be
able to put these things together in a
way that feels more structured
in a world where so many students are
going to be working from home and so
that's why
over the past weekend we launched the
schedules on khan academy there could be
links depending on what social media
channel you're looking at you could also
just do a web search if you just go to
khan academy.org we have banners that
lead you to the schedules and the other
resources that we're having
but that helps structure students days
for uh young students
old you know middle school students high
school students uh elementary school
students and we've been getting a lot of
good feedback from that and we're
constantly tweaking it so it becomes
better and better so please give us
feedback on that but the purpose of this
homeroom that was a long parenthetical
the purpose of this home room is to as
folks work at their own time and pace on
those types of schedules to feel a
connectedness you know when you're in a
real school there's a home room and
there's announcements and we get to see
each other we we get to kind of prepare
our minds for the day and so this is
really for everybody it's for students
it's for parents it's for teachers just
as a way to start their day
and and and in this time of uh social
distancing uh hopefully feel a little
bit connected a couple of announcements
as many of y'all know i've been
mentioning this in the last few live
streams khan academy is a not-for-profit
with the mission of a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere
not-for-profit means no one owns khan
academy it's a public charity i don't
own khan academy you own as much khan
academy as i do
and we are dependent on philanthropic
donations and uh we are
we are proud and we we want to step up
in every way possible to serve everyone
during this situation
but what happens with a not for profit
like ours is our servers are actually
our usage has more than doubled as of
the latest data that i saw from
yesterday and that increases our cost
and
but uh and our funds come from uh
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself so we definitely
uh need help
and so let's see i just
looks like the screen just clipped out
on me oh it's back all right sorry uh so
so so we need help but i do want to uh
thank several
there's many of y'all who've been
donating at all different levels i
definitely want to thank some
corporations who've stepped up in in
record time over the weekend bank of
america was the first to step up when
they found out kind of our situation and
and how much uh the resources we had to
put out there were what we were hoped to
do to get everyone through this school
closure situation and they encouraged us
to think big so bank for america gave a
very generous donation over the weekend
you could read up about that
announcement
and just this morning i really want to
thank
att and google.org for following close
behind bank of america and also stepping
up with significant support so that we
can handle
all the extra programs we want to do
the server costs that have
roughly doubled now
and we were frankly already running at a
deficit before this because you can
imagine uh you know serving up content
we have a team of over 200 folks and
serving up content to uh tens and what
is likely hundreds of millions of folks
uh now um is is does take a lot of
resources so thank you for everyone
there uh so with that said with my with
my uh my asking for support from the
world
and we need more i'll turn to your
questions so
the first question
and this is one we get pretty
consistently is as a parent how should i
figure out what my child should be
learning so in those schedules that we
put out they have and you should be you
know you should definitely feel free to
modify those schedules so they work for
you and depending on
what works for your child
but in each of those areas so for say
say math you know we give some grade
levels that might be appropriate for
students of a certain age and i would
say if your student
has historically felt say confident in
math and has done quite well in math you
can just start them right at grade level
they can take something called the
course challenge that's right from the
course page and on that course challenge
it'll take about 30 to 40 minutes
they'll have to answer about 30 40
questions and then it will
tell them what they got right or wrong
and the things that they got wrong i
would recommend going to those units in
course and so and on those units if the
student feels like they know a good bit
of that unit they can go to the unit
tests and take that and then that'll
give them credit for what they know then
they can focus on the skills that they
don't know and then the game mechanics
for the entire site has unit test course
challenges other things mastery
challenges uh so that it encourages kids
to to show that they have mastery that
they can fill in all those gaps in their
knowledge that they can do the skills in
a mixed topic type of environment so
that's one method if you're a child or
if you're a student and you've maybe
felt a little bit weak in in math
one thing that we've seen tim vandenberg
this uh a teacher that i've been
really really impressed by over over
i've heard about him a couple weeks ago
he actually starts all of his sixth
graders at kindergarten and that's not
to you know talk down to him it's
actually because he has very high
expectations for them what happens there
is that the students by starting at
kindergarten they're able to
build some momentum if obviously a lot
of sixth graders most sixth graders will
get through the kindergarten content
they can do it through the course
challenges in literally uh 30 or 40
minutes then they go to first grade you
can do all of early learning on khan
academy you can do arithmetic and he
also makes all of the students do the
third grade because he sees that that
has a lot of foundational things in it
like your your basic um arithmetic
fluency and your basic multiplication
fluency things like that and then he has
them simultaneously working at grade
level so i think uh this situation
might be especially if you have a child
or if you are a student who's
historically struggled in math i
recommend spending more time so you can
work at grade level and make sure that
you don't have any swiss achieved gaps
going forward and the same thing is true
in english and language arts you should
always be working at a level that you're
getting a few questions wrong it's a
little bit difficult but you can
definitely engage on it uh would be my
best advice since i think over the next
few days and weeks because khan academy
has all of the grade levels it's a good
time to try to triangulate where is that
learning edge and you should be able to
get to it in about a week and then learn
from there and really have strong
foundations
so let's see kaili
kamiyoka says hi sal as a tutor how do
you figure out where the students gaps
are
so a very similar question um would i if
if you really want to go for gaap
funding
you should start students at the very
very basic material that's why we
created mechanisms on khan academy to
accelerate through it but that's really
the only way to go skill by skill and
ensure that students have no gaps and
what we see over and over again is even
students who are a student you know in
middle school
they still have a few gaps or they're
still not completely fluent at certain
things from arithmetic or things that
came before and we see many high school
students who are not fluent at middle
school skills or elementary school
skills and so it's really valuable it
might seem like you're taking a step
back but it's kind of uh go slow to go
fast uh if you take that week
to
start from the beginning and build up
all your skills then when you get to the
middle school math or the algebra you'll
find that you're right in the right
place if you're looking at other topics
on khan academy like biology or physics
i mean i'd advocate the same thing
economics take the course challenge
understand what you know when you don't
know and then go back and fill in those
gaps in the appropriate units
so underground school says other than
career preparation what is the role of
learning in life
so
you know underground school it's
interesting an interesting name
you know it's a deep question of what is
the role you know what is the purpose of
life period uh and and
you know i think one of the things that
makes us as human beings fairly unique i
mean we know it we know what some of
them are we have opposable thumbs
although you know uh all of our our our
primate and ape cousins have have
opposable uh thumbs um
we have uh
we have a a large brains and we walk on
two legs upright
uh and we have language which is maybe a
byproduct of our long break large brains
and maybe all those things come together
the opposable thumbs the the brains and
the language and i think that learning
is one of the most fundamental human
things that makes us feel human and so
i've gotten letters
over the years from khan academy from
people who are past their career or well
into their career and they realized
later in life how much joy there is just
for the sake of learning just trying to
understand this mystery that we find
ourselves in call life understanding the
universe a little better and what i've
told what i've said in multiple live
streams is you know some students have
asked how do i get motivated and i
remind you know that this content that
you can learn on khan academy that you
can learn your textbooks
this is a lot of what you see in a
lesson or a unit is someone's life work
or it's probably many hundreds of
people's life work and they would have
they would done anything to see that
knowledge that you now see how does
photosynthesis work what does
mitochondria do um calculus
you know people like newton and leibniz
spent their last decades uh trying to
derive these things and you can now kind
of understand it in a more distilled
format i think that's incredibly
exciting and uh
and and
it just changes your perspective on
everything and it also just makes you a
better citizen you know in a world where
we want democracy we want people to be
able to participate there's an
obligation on the person themselves to
be as informed as possible to be able to
look at the data that exists in the
world to be able to think critically
about the world and that's what
education is is going to going to
provide you'll also be more fun at
dinner parties better dinner party
conversation
all right kirsten martin says
how does a teacher use khan academy to
teach a class at multiple levels
what should the teacher component focus
on
so uh kirsten
you know in a tr if if we weren't in the
school closure situation and the the
teachers that i've seen use khan academy
to great effect and i've visited
hundreds of classrooms over the years
and tim vandenberg's the most recent um
that i've talked to i haven't visited
his classroom yet
the teachers will spend some time with
the students are learning at their own
time and pace on khan academy
i don't think it's a bad idea to start
all of your students at kindergarten and
then let them progress as quickly as
possible or you know our early learning
and arithmetic and let them progress as
quickly as possible maybe simultaneously
while they do the grade level what tim
has done is he has all the students
started early math but then he also
assigns let's say they're sixth graders
or seventh graders he will use our
assignments functionality to assign unit
one
in sixth grade and then unit two and
what he does is he has a double
expectation for his students he says
remediate fill in those gaps as quickly
as you can if you don't have gaps it'll
happen quite quickly and simultaneously
work on the grade level stuff and i
expect you to be done i expect you to be
done one fourth through the grade one
fourth through the year halfway through
the grade halfway through the year
actually he he makes a grading based on
that but it's a mastery learning
framework so if a student's not quite
there the quarter year mark but then
gets there later on he actually modifies
their grade to reflect that they have
now gotten to that point and that seems
to work really well for him and the way
it flows in the classroom when they're
when classes in session
is he's able to look at the data of what
students are working on who's engaged
who's not engaged obviously he can see
some of that just by looking at the
classroom
and
what what are students having trouble
with and then he can use that to take a
handful of students to do a more focused
intervention or maybe pairs two students
together who are trying to work on the
same skill or maybe pair a student who's
already mastered a concept with the
student who's trying to master the
concept and what you find is it's a very
rich classroom you know a lot of people
imagine that online learning can be kind
of this vulcan or borg reality where
kids are just
on computers and learning
and then kind of their isolated
places but done well it can be highly
highly interactive and and the teacher
is able to form a good connections with
the students students are able to talk
and interact and teach each other and
obviously you learn things the best when
you when you actually have to teach it
um now that we're in this virtual world
i i i've heard of teachers and parents
emulating aspects of that where the kids
are working on khan academy and then
simultaneously you might have a
google hangout or a
zoom conference call or a skype session
at the same time where students know
that they can go on to that and access
their students their peers or their
teacher or a parent
who might be able to help them and you
can imagine in this more virtual world
that we're finding ourselves in a parent
or a teacher or even an older student
could look at the dashboard still and
say hey looks like
five of y'all are really having trouble
with negative numbers and yes khan
academy has resources and that person
said hey make sure you look at the watch
the videos make sure you look at the
explanations on the hints but they could
say hey at 10 a.m i'm going to run a
20-minute session a breakout session on
negative numbers for u5
to really help you through it or you
might see hey you know let's let's khan
academy does certain types of items and
problems but there could be a a really
rich multi-step application problem that
you can say all right
students keep working on khan academy
but half of y'all are ready for this
deeper type of question let's work on
that together and you could do it on a
hangout or a zoom so those are the types
of frameworks but we would love to hear
from all of you teachers uh how you're
using it
so nadia ali says hi my son asks what is
the importance of the points he collect
i answer the more points you score the
smarter you are but he wants to hear it
from you
well i'll give a slightly different
answer what i would say is the more you
learn
um the more
the richer your life will be so that's
the number one thing to remember uh the
points really are
just
points
it's they do you know they do help
unlock things like avatars and things
like that
but you know the way our brains are
wired or many of our brains are wired
things like points and you know i think
even in adulthood many people are still
looking to score points in different
ways
they could call a bank account
appointments uh you know beyond a
certain measure it probably is uh
uh but but you know those are those are
just you know what's known as extrinsic
motivators things that will hopefully
motivate you to get more engaged but the
best motivators are intrinsic motivators
when you realize that the best thing to
do is just
build that learning and maybe you could
view the points we have energy points we
have mastery points you can see your
skills that you've leveled up you know
that's a way to reflect on what you've
what you've learned and that's actually
the the most enriching thing of all uh
more than more than points or anything
else but but that's what the points are
they're indicative of what you've
learned and i wouldn't even say
necessarily smart or not smart uh you
know uh there was a question earlier
about growth mindset actually that's the
next question from mahela lickitch
i apologize if i'm mispronouncing your
name mahalia uh but
the whole principle of growth mindset is
there's people with either a fixed
mindset or a growth mindset fixed
mindset and a domain thinks i'm either
smart or i'm not and a growth mindset
says well no i don't really know my
potential unless i'm always willing to
step out of my comfort zone try things
that are difficult for me recognize that
when i fail at something that's when i'm
growing the most that's my opportunities
growth and
when people have a fixed mindset if they
think they're smart at something many
times they don't want to uh many times
they don't want to
try hard things because it might
undermine their self-perception and if
they think they're not smart at
something they don't want to try it
because they're like well i'm never
going to be good at it but people with a
growth mindset will always say hey
that's a challenge i might not succeed
but i'm going to try it and i'll work on
it so really the points are there to
reward and show how much effort you've
put in and how much you've been willing
to push yourself and that i think is the
muscle that we all want to build and you
know if you look in the world the people
who are disproportionately successful
are the people with growth mindsets the
people who are always looking to
improve themselves push themselves and
aren't trying to say i'm smart or not
smart just i'm just going to keep seeing
what i can do
so
several kaya says anything that we can
do as a volunteer we'd love to be part
of the team thanks for all you do
um
so
the the
there's multiple ways you might
volunteer we have
languages people are subtitling
i think in this time that we find
ourselves in the school closures if
you're in a position
find some kids that you might you know
in your community who might need help
contact some teachers
especially kids who might not have a lot
of resources one try to figure out how
to get them resources i think computers
and internet are a lifeline right now
not just for accessing things like khan
academy but just to be able to connect
with people uh now that we ought to be
socially distant so if you could help
some way in that that could be really
powerful for the world i think if you
could
run
video conferencing tutoring sessions
classes for people who want to learn in
your area
you know we're looking at ways that we
could kind of scale that type of thing
up
i've you know we've recommended our
schedules that people do that that you
know i've already mentioned that
teachers parents older students are able
to organize
create video conferencing places where
people can go get help i think that
could be a great way to volunteer right
now i think there's ways unrelated to
khan academy that could be great to
volunteer now
you know find people who might not have
a lot of connection to other people get
on hangouts with them talk to them i
think people need that
i think if there's elderly people in
your area offer to go buy their
groceries for them drop it off on their
porches i think that could be a great
service so there's a lot of opportunity
for service uh right now but in the
academic realm and khan academy realm i
would say right now it's uh you know run
tutoring sessions for folks and when you
do those tutoring sessions on hangouts
or on a on a zoom session some of it
might be explaining the the concept but
a lot of it might just be motivating hey
remember you could go to khan academy
that's the video hey remember using are
you using it right and they can sign you
up as their coach so you can monitor and
see how they're able to interact and say
hey so and so it looks like you haven't
been working on it what's going on how
can i help you i think that by itself is
a huge huge huge service and we are
running uh i forgot to mention parent
webinars and teacher webinars to help
parents and teachers understand how to
use our tools and our reports a little
bit more so stay tuned for for some of
that
so
i have somal sahu says what is your
typical day like
well i think that changes depending on
whether you talk about the last week or
or before the last week uh you know this
this week has been a very interesting
week for everyone um
but uh given and i i feel lucky that
khan academy is in a position to help uh
the situation because as i've said in
other live streams there's three things
that people are worried about
their health and your mental and
physical health first and foremost the
second is the economics of the situation
and there's a lot of people struggling
especially as restaurants and and
and hotels and airlines are having to
lay off folks so it's a really tough
tough situation we're in
but the third thing is there's a lot of
kids out of school and there's a lot of
adults uh that are uh home and we're all
in the same room together and and how do
we navigate that and how do we make sure
that people keep learning and um
so anyway
my day uh
you know yesterday i woke up super early
we got a bunch of press inquiries uh
just so that i we're leveraging to help
communicate that these resources exist
then
we had this
live stream simultaneously we're trying
to still put some content out i have a
few that i i'm in my queue there's
another coronavirus video that i'd
actually like to make to just help
explain and and
and people appreciate that you know the
social distancing is something to take
quite seriously and the more the more
seriously we do it and the sooner we do
it
the more likely we are able to navigate
this thing in a very good way and it
wouldn't hurt the economy too much um
and yeah but you know right now it's
just constant our whole team is now
virtual and so
even while i'm talking my my i've gotten
four text messages that i haven't looked
at yet so it is just like a bit of a war
room where we're trying to figure out
what goes on and that day's going pretty
long right now i mean in the old days
like two weeks ago
my day would be i try to split my day
about a third or third or third about
third is i still create content i still
try to make videos or or create other
things about a third of my time is
working with the team uh to help think
about where this the product go what
features can we add and then another
third of my time is roughly
doing things like this uh external
communications fundraising talking press
um etc
so yeah that's that's my average day
okay
uh galaxywolfplays
says will there be any new updates for
the website and app
so in the long run for sure 100 i mean
that we have a whole team uh working on
this you know even as this crisis was
unfolding we we've actually have to
re-architect our entire for you know
back end of our infrastructure of our of
our site just so it can continue to
scale and obviously that's even more of
an imperative now that our usage has
more than doubled over the last few days
uh but we have yes we do have plans on
a whole host of features we usually
launch them around back to school time
period uh but yeah we have a whole you
know
and there's aspirations for sure over
the next year two years three years of
the
the types we want to do we want to add
more content
we want to make it easier to navigate we
eventually want to make it easier ways
you know a lot of people ask how do i
know where to start and i gave i've
given you some
ways to do it but we want to make that
even simpler so there's just a ton of
things that we definitely want to add to
the site heather sylvester says my son
tried to log in the other day and start
where he left off in algebra one but is
making him start all the way back to the
beginning is there another way around it
uh well i'm sorry to hear that um
i'm guessing if your son was
uh
maybe what you're saying is where he
left off in algebra one in his algebra
one class so my advice to your son
and to you is he should take the course
challenge in algebra one and then that
will give him a good sense of what he
knows and doesn't know in algebra one
and we do that because every course you
know there's some courses people do
around the world in roughly the same
order at the same pace but it's usually
a little bit different and so if he
takes that course challenge he'll know
where he is and then he can then focus
on the units where he has gaps the stuff
that he knows it literally could take
him a few hours to show that he has
mastered that and that's good because
then he will know that material that
much better he will have reviewed it a
few months after because that's another
issue that a lot of kids have they'll go
through the material that's covered in
class but then by the end of the year
and for sure after the end of summer
they've forgotten it so this is a good
chance to review and refresh and algebra
is one of those foundational things not
just for the rest of math but also for
science and economics and pretty much
anything else you're going to do in life
so yeah i would say the course challenge
use unit tests that'll help them
accelerate there's also things called
mastery challenges those will all help
him accelerate if he already knows some
of that material it'll take him a few
hours to get to a mastery in a lot of
that and then he'll see the areas where
he's to work more on it and he should be
able to get if he does know 60 or 70 of
the material already uh he should get to
60 or 70 percent mastery quite quickly
and then now he can he can progress from
there and i would say once he's done
with algebra one he should continue on
into geometry or algebra two or or
whatever else uh uh interests him
so next we have uh
david manos and first of all i want to
thank david he's one of our teacher
ambassadors these are incredible
teachers around the country and world
who are khan academy super users and not
only our super users with their own
students but help other teachers i use
khan academy so i just wanted to thank
david for for being one of the
ambassadors uh so he says thank you to
you and your team for all you all do
well thank you for thanking us a couple
of questions are there plans to provide
down global downloadable packets for
teachers who need to provide paperwork
for this
and two are there plans to extend upper
math content further going beyond
calculus so on the first one
we don't have current plans but that's
an interesting idea you're an ambassador
so let our team know i'm assuming that
would be for the younger age group that
might need more paper type worksheets
that's an interesting idea and i think
we
we wouldn't maybe have thought about it
two weeks ago because we've always
viewed ourselves as kind of
going
side by side with what the traditional
kind of paper-based curriculum is but in
this type of reality it is something we
should explore
uh are there plans to extend upper math
content
further going beyond calculus so we do
have video content going beyond calculus
multi-variable differential equations
linear algebra we have statistics too
which you could argue it's not
necessarily beyond calculus
the statistics has exercises
so long term yes i would love to do it
long term in the short term we probably
aren't we there might be something in
multi-variable but i i can't promise
that uh just yet
um
let's see
bunny hernandez says
we'd love to help khan academy raise
funds how can we get in touch
so depending if you'd like to donate
khan academy.org donate
there's also some links i think if
you're streaming in or if you're getting
stream on facebook we're going to put it
there on youtube you might see some
donate links
if you're looking at kind of fundraising
in a bigger way like helping fundraise
from other people uh pop us a uh an
email at s-con
khan academy.org and i'll afford it to
the right to the right person
so it looks like we are all oh look i
just saw the screen kind of clipped out
um
so it looks like we're pretty close to
time now
so a couple of a couple of um
announcements so next week we're going
to change the live stream
the live stream is going to be at 12
noon pacific 3 pm eastern as of monday
we're going to be doing this live stream
every week today for the foreseeable
future to just help us feel connected
during this time so it's going to be at
12 noon pacific 3 p.m eastern starting
monday this was based on everyone's
feedback of what would work across time
zones and
things like that
and i really look forward to seeing you
all you know take care of yourselves
stay socially distant but
stay socially distanced but not socially
distant um you know interact with your
friends i've been interacting with
friends and family many of people
haven't talked to for a while but doing
it on hangouts and chats and things like
that and it's actually helped i think
everyone gets through this and you know
as i said it every at the end of every
live stream uh this is something you
know i i remind myself whenever it's
like oh i'm in this house for an awfully
long time
whatever else is that the whole world is
going through this and you know it's
it's it's a it's a crummy situation
but uh there's very few times in history
where the whole world has um
gone through something like this and as
bad as it is it's also an opportunity
where i think we're seeing the the good
in everyone and everyone is trying to
help everyone and uh you know so i think
we can all appreciate that aspect of the
crisis we we are in and once again thank
you all for for joining this helps me
feel connected to all of you uh and and
thank you to everyone who's helped out
donated uh given your donations we need
help our server costs
are growing very fast uh and and another
thanks to the corporations that have
begun to step up you know bank of
america stepped up over the weekend and
then today we just announced 18t in
google.org
and any corporate leaders out there we
need more help there's many many
students on khan academy right now who
who need our help to learn and parents
and teachers who need our support thank
you very much
you